capisco anche stare in compagnia libera
[Musica]
quella se ti ringrazio di questo video
sono fa vj oggi siamo su file night
freddi non sapevo neanche dell'esistenza
di questo gioco perché nessuno me ne ha
parlato questo è un menù
ok poi in high tech freddy's due ragazze
di un gioco bellissimo dove ci sono
questi pupazzi belli la prima notte a
mezzanotte siamo perfetto devo
sopravvivere delle notti qui prende il
posto di merda per casa sì se in
pizzeria presidi altra cosa ti porto
quanto forma a jesi una profitto ma
prosciutto perfetto è pronunciarci mi
stai dando fastidio quindi team grazie
per aver chiamato o vado a [ __ ] forse
dovevo ascoltarlo ma non importava che
tanto me ne frego cosa sono
giorno mi piace ma cos'è io giro per le
camera e così questa cosa avevo capito
effettivamente a salve sappiatelo il mio
prossimo compleanno lo faccio qui tutti
invitati siete tutti verranno tutti sono
convinto comunque comandi sono 206 ha
scritto che c'è la torcia per control
c'è solo contro che poi prendere non è
neanche tanto impegnativo se non fosse
che le porte sono mezze aperte ed è un
posto di merda sarebbe anche divertente
solo che non questo tizio veramente un
film non ho capito sto cosa però
buongiorno nome ragazzo sono tutti sono
bellissimi io voglio assolutamente come
regalo e lo voglio è nata a natale nello
regalate ragazzi voglio questo tutta la
vita bellissimo ti chiamerò alan perché
chiaramente un figlio alan ascolta mito
tu mi piaci di più degli atleti sono
brutti e veramente [ __ ] sta cosa con
gente che crede che il bambino il
bambino che si è infilato il suo posto
non è uscito vedere qualcuno mentre
faceva il compleanno si è infilato sotto
i tavoli ed è rimasto lì e non so che
ride da mezz'ora a la cosa cazzo stai
facendo lì disegnato rock n roll fa mica
c'è alan guara io lo capisco che stare
in compagnia list i [ __ ] non è
proprio
il massimo della vita per o mio dio c'è
anche stare in compagnia lyria sporca la
buttana casa dove casse fosse ma non ci
crederò mai ma [ __ ] siete riusciti
a consigliarmi il videogioco che mi ha
scassato le cuffie grazie grazie di dio
ragazzino ero preparato a sta cosa
quindi nave va ne aveva un altro paio
però che a [ __ ] per capire un attimo
come che sono morto di preciso che non
ho capito una sega di colore niente mi è
spuntato un tizio a caso da davanti più
bello soprattutto era molto bello e ha
capito una roba ma se lascio la musica
che corre senza senza tirare senza
premere su cosa cosa succede se si
specchia la musica qual è il problema
che hanno capito cosa
alan alan mi metto la musica subito la
rivetta l'alimento è meglio subitissimo
proprio eccola qui perfetto sei contento
è contento a un perfetto dove dove è
andato e di nuovo qui perfetto della
scotta mia la tu non sei portato per la
musica rock
fatene una cazzo di ragione e smettila
di tartassare mi maroni a me perché noi
che posso stare tutta la notte a
controllare il t [ __ ] che è andato
via è andato via anche l'altro porca la
[ __ ] abbiate pazienza ragazzo io non
riesco a capire che non musica ma la
musica non so che cosa succede quando
finisce la musica ma non deve finire
perchè qualcuno mi spiega il senso di
salandra svolta un attimo ma tu continua
persone hanno domandato a finire
buongiorno nel 66 bellissimi non potevi
stare qui insieme i tuoi amici proprio
devi stare zitti dà fastidio alan ti
prendi qualcosa che siete tutti e tre
molto simpatici però per favore dirgli
qualcosa perché non si possa cioè mio
dio
e successo
a sole 6 6 di mattina sì sì ho vinto o
vince lo fa sono sopra visto un 6 del
mattino perfetto ragazzi ce l'abbiamo
fatta
seconda notte le gambe seconda notte
perché io ci sono anche tornati in
questo posto di merda perché fatemi
capire io sono veramente è tornato in
questo posto di che è successo perché ci
sono umore bruti ragazzi spiega ragazzi
segnali interrotto benissimo sono di due
non già non ci sono bella sta cosa
regala cosa ci fa quel tizio là sopra
sentite e la music box per questa la
devo tenere ragazzi ma devo tenere per
forza perché non capito cosa succede se
non da meno la tengo
ma di sicuro niente di bello senti alan
alan come cazzo è alan di pace domandato
alan ragazzi non trovo alan alan che
ogni tre secondi ci insegna l'inter
hotel che era già sentite a salve no no
no no no no qualche siringa sei molto
gentili e ti ringrazio però non lo
voglio il dolcetto non è che lo sappia
avrei scommesso che prima o poi sarebbe
spuntato alcuno qui sotto ma mai c'è un
artigiano no no no no no ma continuerà a
non capire che cazzo succede se non vi
costa cosa no preferisco non saperlo ok
sono morto morto fantastiche stato bel
nome e meno male che stavolta nelle
cuffie sono a posto mi sarei potuto
incazzare altamente il bello visto gioca
che ci sono anche due telecamere
nascoste nei condotti è bellissimo
fatemi capire perché perché se stronzate
non ce le metterei mai due telecamere
ricordati più cose entrano i ladri ma
non c'era mentre rimane che mi state
simpaticissimi quando gironzolate a caso
diciamo ragazzi che cazzo da alan ma
piace allora ascoltami ascoltami
favore ti prego ti prego vattene
affanculo
e non è che posso stato tutta la notte a
controllare se nicoletta noi ci avrei
anche i cazzi miei
sono dati da fan culo tutti e due no no
no no no no no no e tu chi cazzo sei
andato no no no no si va beh ragazzi non
posso non toglierò mai più sta schermata
meno non se qualcuno mi arriva davanti
mi incazzo ragazzi cosa devo fare
ma se io mi metto st maschera sono a
posto non mi trovate cioè sono più bello
buongiorno salve sale sale sale si legge
molto bello quand on era qua prima se no
qui ecco perfetto eccoti che i bastardo
ho trovato l'orsacchiotto né però non ho
capito lo è sono finiti gli altri non mi
interessa sinceramente ti ho visto ho
finito la torcia su riuscito a finire la
torcia porca [ __ ]
salve mi mancano due ore e ancora non so
resistere
posso resistere di guardare così però
con una bella persona senti zio non è
che posso fare io ho creduto apparivano
due ceffoni che non ha idea ma possono
anche a premere
[ __ ] dovete morire tutti
giusto per capire
allora è successo alla calma ciò che
sembra ragazzi ma anche un'ora madre
quale fa le torte è una tu stai ferma lì
un attimo tu vedi di non muoverti
tardiva un ceffone
cosa devo fare adesso per sopra cosa
cosa devo fare
giuro su chi volete che questa è
l'ultima volta perché poi i [ __ ]
c'è noi che possono rovinarmi la vita
così davis come se le sarebbe stato così
una melma
ma qualsiasi cosa proprio grazie per
avermelo conosco i gentilissimi guardini
dovette delle cuffie infine nel dubbio
che il tizio all'inizio che parlava che
ho schivato violentemente mi spiegasse
punto del tipo cosa saliva la maschera
però non lo caga taji strisce è un ora è
passata tranquillo che ne mancano 5
nella lo sapevo devo stare anche
abbastanza attento anche la torcia non
si spenga perché sennò ce l'ha nessuno
ok ok
io faccio così schifo a tutti e tre ogni
volta finché non non passano le ore e
stato tutto il tempo così volete che si
muove bastardi sarà una lunghissima
nottata però se devo passarla così
io